RENEE H.: I was a
child during the war
when, the Germans came
into Czechoslovakia.
I was not yet six years
old, and at that time,
I was living in Brno, which
was the third largest city.
Things were not explained to me.
Children at that time
were kept in ignorance
of much of what was going
on, politically or otherwise,
and only when it impinged
on actual family events
were some explanations given.
I have one recollection
of the German presence
of that time, which was
when Hitler supposedly
went through the town and I
do remember my father saying
that I was not to
go in the streets.
I first remember seeing
German soldiers just walking
on the street, nothing
happened much in the beginning.
But slowly there was
abuse, and the abuse
came not so much
from the Germans
alone as it came from
the native population,
the Slovaks themselves.
I remember coming home one day
and seeing my mother sewing
on the star on my coat and
I was aware of the fact
that this was a way
of singling us out
and I remember saying,
"Let's not do this
because then we can't hide."
And she said, "We have
to, that is the decree."
And what happened
in the town itself
was the closing in
of the neighborhood.
The Jews, we did
not have a ghetto,
and yet there was a
ghetto atmosphere there.
Because what happened is that
certain neighborhoods where
Jews lived which were more
elegant neighborhoods they
were told they had to leave.
They could not stay.
So they had to move into a
smaller and smaller enclave,
the main street of
which was Judengasse.
And I had always been a child
that used to roam around,
to my parents despair.
But so I got to know
the city terribly well.
And what I would
do in order to be
able to continue that sense
of freedom that I had,
would be constantly
to try to wear a scarf
to cover up the
Jewish star, and I
would pretend that if anybody
addressed me in some way
I wouldn't understand
what they were saying.
But I did feel that
every exit into the town
outside of my immediate
home was into a very
hostile and dangerous
environment.
That I always could
be found out and I
would have fantasies about
what would happen to me if they
found me out, and it
was always accompanied
by my immediately running
back home, to touch base.
INTERVIEWER 1:
What would happen?
RENEE H.: I, the
worst that I ever saw
anybody was to get a
very thorough beating,
and curiously enough I
always expected the beating,
but I never received it.
I never could understand
why, and one day, I
do remember asking
a teacher whom
I knew who lived in
the neighborhood,
as to why everybody left me
alone even though they saw me
on the street.
And she said to me, "That's
because you have blonde hair."
Somehow, that
seemed to me to make
me a little more acceptable.
But I was aware
of the fact that I
didn't want to identify
with the Slovaks,
and yet I wanted the
freedom of the town which
I had gotten so used to.
And I wanted to know
what was going on,
because my parents
weren't telling me much,
and I wanted to
explore and sense
what really was happening.
And I,
But the worst parts
for me at the time
was watching the transports.
And the transport would
just suddenly appear,
and I remember that we would
hear certain sounds of boots
on the street, and
usually, whenever
there was a transport
it was accompanied
by 10 to 12 soldiers
coming, marching together
from house to house, and
gathering all the people
and knocking on the doors and
saying, "You have an hour."
People had only an hour in
which they could gather families
together.
Often, what would happen is
if the whole family was not
together, a child would be
sent out to bring in the rest,
try to, and that
used to horrify me
because there would
sometimes be a child who
would come running back crying,
"I don't know where Papa is."
And so, what happened was that
there was all these transports
would get together
on the street,
and the people would
wait there, hoping
that the family, the rest
of the family would come.
And eventually what happened
is that, which I did not
know because no one ever
told me those things,
and it was not possible
to ask questions
because every time
you asked a question,
they just give you a slap.
And what I did find out was
that eventually families
were united at a central
post, because when
the rest of the family came
home and asked where they were,
they would rush to
the police station
and immediately give
themselves up to the Gestapo.
And in 1943, my family
decided that they
had to save part of the family.
They saw these
transports coming,
and it was just a
monthly occurrence
and there would be 2,000 people
sometimes in the transports.
Sometimes there would
be considerably less.
We used to live in
terror of these boots
and we lived on the fourth
floor in the apartment
and my parents were both
deaf, and I had a deaf sister,
so I became the ears.
I would have to warn them
that the transport was coming.
And what I would do is we
would all rush in the back room
and when they knocked on
the door, we didn't answer.
We were in the back
room just trying
to be as quiet as possible
and what happened is
that as a result of this,
the responsibility was on me to
always hear what was going on,
because any time I heard
10 boots marching down
around the corner I would
run immediately home
and tell everybody to
go into the apartment.
And, sometimes we were
together, sometimes we were not.
And we used to pray that nobody
would be coming up the stairs
just at the same time.
And it got so that we all got to
be very, very good in spotting.
What happened is
that we developed
eyes that looked for
everything, and I was the ears.
And so in the
middle of the night
sometimes people would
come up the stairs,
but there were no transport
collections at night,
but they would be what they
called, "neighborhood spies."
People who tried to find
out whether the family
was still there and so on.
And we had to watch
out for that too,
and I ended up so that I
was constantly listening
and I was able to
identify sounds.
And, but in, by 1943,
my parents realized
that it was just hopeless, that
there was no point in trying
to live in this fearful way.
And so they decided to send my
sister and me to a farm family
out in the country, for
which they paid great sums
and I had to hide the
fact that I was Jewish.
And I remember my mother taking
all the stars off my clothes
again and sending me off.
And this was in the s--
I would say around the
spring or the summer of 1943.
I would, I was taken by
a person who was also
deaf to his mother's
home in the countryside,
somewhere in the, near the Tatra
Mountains, at the foothills.
And I was introduced as a very
distant relationship whose
parents were in the
hospital and sick
and I had to be taken care of
for a certain amount of time
until I got the
message to come back.
I was told never to tell
anyone I was Jewish.
I was told that even though
I didn't have to go to church
that I had to pretend that I...
everything Christian
was very familiar to me,
and very desired by me.
So that, for example,
if the priest went by
I had to cross myself.
It used to be terrible
to do that for me
because I felt that I
was going to in some way
have to pay for this,
but I nevertheless
knew that I had
my sister as well
to take care of, who was a year
and a half younger than myself.
And I never saw my
parents again afterwards.
In the spring of 1944, the
son came back to the farm
and announced to me that
my parents had failed
to pay for the last five
months of my stay there,
and consequently somebody else
was going to take care of us
in Bratislava itself.
So when we went
back to Bratislava,
there were various people
we knew who had papers,
forged papers, and they told
us that it would be impossible
for us to have
the forged papers.
When we said, "Where
are our parents?"
They said they didn't know,
but they were still in hiding.
They did never,
they never told us
that they had already been
taken by the last transport out
of Bratislava.
And finally I
remember one evening,
hiding on the third floor of
a building which was really
the place where a tailor
kept his workshop.
And we had to stay out
of the place all day
long because he
had workmen there,
and as he explained to us that
those, many of those workmen
were very Antisemitic.
And if they knew
that we were there,
spending the night
in the dark, they
would betray us without a doubt.
And so I remember spending
the days, for three weeks,
on the streets, going into
shops when I had to go in,
going into the church,
going all over the place.
I remember one episode
which was very harrowing,
was when somebody who knew
my parents recognized me,
and it was rather easy to
recognize me at that time
because I had very blond,
very tightly curled
hair, sort of like
an Afro in blond.
And he immediately
says, "come here,
I'm going to take care of you."
And I knew immediately that
I just could not trust him.
In fact, my, I had lost
trust in everybody.
I was very suspicious and very
careful to watch and listen
for any force or
difficult notes,
and I said, "Never, I
wasn't going to come."
And I started to run
and he chased me,
and it was a very good thing
that my knowledge of Bratislava
came to my aid because
I was able to weave
my way around
streets and corners
and little openings in
buildings and finally I
managed to lose him.
I noticed one thing when
I came back to Bratislava,
that there were no
more transports,
there were no more gatherings.
And the transports
used to terrify me
because the speed of them was
so horrendous where they were
trying to force, they
would yell at the people
and say, "get out.
Get out.
Quickly, get out.
Gather together.
You can't take this suitcase.
You can take this suitcase.
Only a little bit with you.
No, you mustn't
take this blanket."
And they would just
force the blanket away.
In the process also there would
be a lot of hitting, especially
of old people, and of
sick people and children,
and the shoving and pushing,
and those gatherings of people
just terrified me.
I really, it was
a way of behaving
which I could never
experience except in, not
even in nightmares.
I even remember my nightmares
as being mild compared to this.
But what was terrible
is that it was
the behavior towards
the very people
that the Jewish
religion says must
have a great deal
of kindness, who
are the sick, the
old, and the children.
And I saw everything
being done which
was opposed to what I believed
in and what I had grown up in.
And I remember when I
came back to Bratislava,
one of the things I noticed that
those transports had ceased.
So it was really, in one sense,
a relief, but in another sense
a terribly scary thing
because I suddenly
realized that I might be the
last, one of the few last Jews
left in the town, that
they all had been taken
except for the
three or four people
I knew who were
on forged papers.
And the thought of being one
of the last Jews was terrible.
I couldn't bear it.
I kept thinking, "no, I don't
want to be the last one alive."
And I must have realized
that many of them
went to death
because otherwise I
wouldn't have said
that, "I don't
want to be the last one alive."
And finally, after three weeks
of living on the streets,
being terrified of the thought
of meeting the man who had
chased me again, being terrified
of meeting anyone who knew me
as a Jew.
I had been away from the
town for about nine months,
so I had hoped that somehow
I, in growing I had somehow
become less noticeable.
But after three weeks
of living like that,
the man said the people
had gotten suspicious
because they found bread crumbs,
and they were complaining
and they thought that the
owner of this workshop
had harbored some fugitives.
And so he finally told
me he couldn't keep me.
I had to find some
other accommodation.
And I took my suitcase and
my sister looking for a place
to stay.
And I would go to
places where I knew
people who were Christians.
I knocked on the
door and they slammed
the door right in my face
and not saying a word,
not explaining, just as if I
were just a beggar at the door
and they just closed
the door in my face.
And finally I went to
the home of these friends
took my parents who were
living on a forged passport,
and they did the same thing.
And then I knew indeed that
I was the last Jew left.
There was nothing for me to do.
For two days, we
were scrounging.
We had no money.
We were scrounging around,
trying to find food
and finally I said to my
sister, "we can't live that way,
we will die on the street.
So we might as well
just go to the police."
And I went to the police
and I said my name
and I said my
parents' name, and I
said I would like to join them.
And the police were amused.
They first laughed,
and then they
realized that I was
perfectly serious.
And they...
suddenly realized that I had
presented them with a problem.
They didn't know
what to do with me.
They didn't know what
to do, so they told me
that I could sit on the
bench and I spent the night
in the police
station on the bench
while they were trying to
find out what to do with me.
They didn't explain
anything to me.
One of the policemen,
I remember,
said, "well, we are trying to
find where your parents are."
And they finally must
have found out somehow
because I was immediately
put on a truck
and driven into
Hungary, and that
was in Sered, which
was a gathering
point for the last remaining
transports coming out
of Bratislava because
nothing was going directly
from Bratislava.
I arrived there to discover
that two weeks before my parents
had been put on the
train to Auschwitz.
This was the first time
I heard about Auschwitz.
I didn't know anything about it.
And I was finally put on one
train, and it was a cattle car
and I, in some ways,
was terribly relieved
to be there because here
I was among Jews again.
They were all
strangers, but still
the fact that they were Jews
was very important to me.
INTERVIEWER 2: Say how old
you were during all this time.
RENEE H.: I was, at that
time I was nine years old.
And I had my sister who
was seven and a half,
and to whom I had to
explain everything,
who had to be basically taken
care of because she only knew
the sign language and
I could sign with her,
but she didn't know
how to communicate yet
with the hearing people.
And so I was really constantly
having to hold her by her hand
so that, because I couldn't call
her, I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't ever
lose sight of her
because in the
milling of the people
we could have been separated.
And we finally were
put on the train,
and I was told that I would
be going to Auschwitz.
And to me, of course,
it was just an image
of my rejoining my parents.
We were on the
train for five days
and during the whole
process of our trip,
we would have to stop because
there was bombing going on.
Sometimes the bombs sounded
as if they were very close,
and we thought that they
would get the train.
And we were I would say
maybe 300 people in each car.
And my sister and I sat on the
suitcase the whole five days
that we were in the train.
And at one point the
bombing, at one point
sounded as if it were the
front of the car had been hit.
It was so loud, and the car
itself jumped the tracks
and we were stuck there for
what seemed to me forever.
And one day, as we were
sort of sitting in the car,
we were told that we would
not be going to Auschwitz,
that we would be re-routed.
And I remember having
to get out of the car
because it had jumped the
tracks and there was no way
for it to move and crossing the
tracks, going into another car,
and spending another
three days in the tracks.
They did, the Germans
did provide food for us,
but it was so minimal.
It was just a slice, two or
three slices of bread and water
and that was all.
And, uh, some of
us were so weak we
could barely make it across
the tracks to the other.
So we had to help each other
and for some strange reason
my sister and I, maybe
because we were so young,
we were, somehow
had managed to get
through the ordeal of
being eight days cooped up
in a very tight space.
And after about three days,
we arrived in Bergen-Belsen.
And then there was a long march.
And the march was the
most horrendous thing
I have ever experienced
because after eight days,
the people just were
in no shape to walk
from the station to the
reception house at the camp.
And there, that march
which was, seemed endless.
It was, it looked enormously
long, maybe in my mind
now, it seems
almost three hours,
but it couldn't have been.
But there we would slowly
walk and the Germans
kept shouting and yelling and
there were truncheons and dogs
and they would
fall on the people,
asking them to hurry and hurry.
And I remember the first
night falling asleep.
I had nothing to eat for a long,
long time, nothing to drink,
but I fell asleep, and
I remember thinking,
life had played a
terrible trick on me
because I wasn't in
Auschwitz with my parents.
And I remember saying to
myself as I fell asleep,
"I will never stop
looking for them."
When we came in with the
transport to Bergen-Belsen,
the separation occurred
in the train station
already, so that when
we started our march,
I already noticed that there
were no men around and no boys.
And when I came to look
at those transports, um,
I noticed that one
of the soldiers who
used to be very
irritated with me
all the time, especially
when I started
to ask in perfect
German, "could I
please call out
my mother's name?"
I knew my mother
couldn't hear me
but I thought maybe somebody
who knew that she was deaf
would tell her that I had
been calling out her name.
And I would call out her
name over and over again.
By doing that, one day for
about the fifth or sixth time,
the soldier so lost his
temper, he just picked me up
and flung me against a stone.
And I lost consciousness
at that time.
And the immediate result
was that I lost for,
temporarily my hearing,
which was in some way to me
a sense of tremendous
worry because I
had to be my sister's ears.
I had to hear for her.
And I was afraid
that I had really had
my hearing permanently damaged.
But after about five or six
days, my hearing came back.
Later on, in
Bergen-Belsen, I realized
that my sister was being
watched by the camp doctor.
I do not know who it was.
He was a German
doctor, but he would
come by the children's
barracks all the time,
come to my sister, pinch
her cheeks, pull her ears,
and try to be very
friendly with her.
And then, one day he
said to me that he
would be able to give us
oranges and chocolates
if I allowed my sister
to go into the hospital
for a few days.
And my sister was
perfectly well,
so I couldn't understand why
he wanted her in the hospital
and I just was very sassy
and I said, "no, you are not,
because if you are,
I'm going to kick you."
And I went up and sort of
said, I am really going to,
I'm serious, I mean it.
And so he laughed and
then forgot about it.
Later on, the
Blockalteste told me
that he had hoped to be
able to use my sister
for scientific research.
Right across from us
was a charnel house
filled with corpses,
not just inside
but overflowing all over.
There were corpses all over.
I lived, walked
beside dead people
and after a while, it just
got to be so that one noticed
and one had to say
to oneself, "I'm
not going to see who it is.
I'm not going to
recognize anyone
in this person who
is lying there."
And, it got to the
point where I realized
that I had to close my
eyes to a number of things.
Otherwise, I would not have
survived even at that time
because I saw people
around me going mad.
I was not only having to live
with all of these things,
but with madness.
One thing I did receive
from the woman in Sered
was a small bag
of tea which I was
able during the time
of the typhus epidemic
to exchange for a
vaccine for my sister,
and I was told it
was a typhus vaccine.
Whether it was one
or not, I'm not sure,
but the fact is that my sister
never did get the typhus.
I did
and so one of the
saddest thing in my life
has been that I have no
recollection of the liberation
because I was totally
ill with the typhus.
I have no recollection of what
happened when the English came
to Bergen-Belsen.
I was very near death.
Had I had to wait another
two days for the English,
I would not have survived.
And, the, it's, I have brooded
on that, that I have not
been conscious at
what I consider
to be the most important
INTERVIEWER 2:
What happened next?
RENEE H.: experience.
I came to Sweden.
I was given over to a doctor
in Sweden who immediately
decided to fatten me up.
Because I weighed at
the age of eleven,
I weighed as much as a
three-year-old child.
And had a big pot belly.
My sister is alive and she
is, came to New York with me.
She went to a school.
She went to the Lexington
School for the Deaf.
She married.
She has three children.
Coming to the United
States was a great shock.
I happened to come
on, in August of 1948.
It was the hottest day in the
history of the United States.
I had come from Sweden and
I walked out of the plane,
and I remember turning around
and saying, "I'm going back."
Because not only was
it very, very hot,
but at the airport, greeting
this plane which had taken us
24 hours to fly from
Stockholm to New York,
I was suddenly faced by a
whole panoply of black faces.
Nobody in Sweden had
told me that there were
Negroes in the United States.
I knew that they were in
Africa, but to suddenly come
into New York and see
all those black faces,
I was sure I had come
into the wrong country.
I was supposed to come
to the United States,
and here was this hot place
with, all the black people.
INTERVIEWER 1: What country?
RENEE H.: Par--
What place?
What--
INTERVIEWER 2: New York.
She--
INTERVIEWER 1: I know.
But where do you
think you-- you got?
Where did they--
RENEE H.: I thought I
was somewhere in Africa,
I had landed
somewhere in Africa.
It was so hot.
INTERVIEWER 1: The plane went
to another place this time?
RENEE H.: That's right.
That's right.
It was exactly,
it was, it was my
having in some way sensed
that life was playing tricks
on me all the time, that I
wasn't going to the places
I thought I was going to.
And then, at the ramp
were my relatives,
waiting for me,
none of whom I knew.
I had never met them.
They had all left long
before I was born.
They were yelling and screaming,
"Renée, Renée, Renée."
So I knew that I was where
I was supposed to be,
but what was strange was
having to get adjusted.
Not only to a totally different
milieu, but to relatives
I had absolutely no inkling of.